at johannesburg's biggest airport an
exodus has begun as british tourists and
dual nationals scramble to get home
very emotional
i was happy to see my family but i want
to get home to my husband and my kids
now
yeah so
i hope i can make this fly
but as travel bans kick in flights are
harder to find many now feel stranded i
must say i had a good cry last night
shea is in cape town visiting family and
is trying to get home to some albans it
leaves me with very very limited options
to actually get back um at the moment
i'm looking at flying by a zanzibar
that seems to be the only country that
um you know i could possibly get back
from without paying
the 2250 pounds that the uk is demanding
for quarantine it's just three days
since south africa first reported the
new strain named omicron by the world
health organization and declared a
variant of concern due to its multiple
mutations around the world scientists
are racing to answer the key questions
is it more infectious will it evade our
vaccines
the sensible thing at this stage is to
be precautionary uh and then uh for us
if if things look as if they're less bad
than uh
currently they might be uh then we can
ease back but it makes sense to take
precautions early on uh and in
particular take precautions to slow down
the arrival of this in the uk
for now at least in britain it's
business as usual but with belgium
reporting the first case of the variant
in europe some scientists believe covid
restrictions should be tightened up if
it's already been identified saying
belgium you can't rely on country of
origin
of traveler origin we think we have to
assume
that people can pick it up and so
everybody should be doing pcr tests i
think we should consider
reinstituting isolation on return from
international travel in general
both pfizer and novovax have said
they've started work on new vaccines to
target the variant already it seems they
can't come soon enough iva bennett sky
news